imagine you just picked up your copy of
cyberpunk 2077
and you are just enthralled in the busy
metropolis of night city
you don't even want to play the main
story instead
wandering down each street corner and
entering
every building to see what you can find
while exploring the district of haywood
you take a wrong turn and end up
somewhere you shouldn't be
and suddenly you are surrounded by one
of night city's
dangerous street gangs but it's not the
territorial valentinos
the cyberpsychotic maelstrom or even
the crazed scavengers it's the bozos
a group that's used biosurgery to turn
themselves
into killer clowns and as they step
closer
their large feet slapping the pavement
they all begin to laugh
before one of them plunges a knife into
your gut
okay i should probably clarify before
going any further
no a group of evil killer clowns has
not been confirmed to appear in
cyberpunk 2077
and i highly doubt they will as much as
i
would absolutely love that but the bozos
are a real gang
in the cyberpunk universe in fact there
are a
ton of bizarre and strange groups
written throughout the years for the
pen and paper rpg and that's what we're
going to be talking about today
some of these have had a major presence
in the fiction and others are just
one-off jokes so hopefully you'll get
some good laughs
and who knows maybe one of these groups
will show up in the game
in one form or another let's start by
talking about
prankster gangs groups that are less
concerned with serious organized crime
and more with mischief and mayhem this
nicely brings us back to the group we
started with
the bozos which yes are known as the
ultimate
killer clown organization the bozos
originally just bothered people with
clown related pranks
such as dropping water balloons on them
but after taking on a new leader
known as the great bozo their pranks
became
a lot more deranged as previously
mentioned the bozos aren't dressed like
clowns but turn themselves
into clowns by biosculpting their bodies
with
long feet large red noses and white skin
truly the stuff of nightmares another
prankster gang
is the vamps also known as the
philharmonic vampires
they dress up in tuxedos wear capes and
have
vampire teeth they are by far the most
harmless of the gangs in cyberpunk
doing acts like putting plants inside
convertibles on the street
or making giant naked inflatable dolls
of the governor
no one's really sure what their
motivation is but it mostly seems to be
in good
fun they do have a weird hatred for
mimes though
which puts them at odds with the
juilliard
a defensive gang made up of a collective
of street performers
they formed out of a desire to give
street performers in 2020
some much needed protection their motto
kill a mime
go to jail perhaps a more sympathetic
group
the juilliard are still quite dangerous
with members typically keeping a machine
gun in their viola case
and if you aren't a street performer
under their protection best or clear
their territory
unless you want a juggling club to the
kneecaps
another performance based gang is the
djs
however unlike the juilliard the djs
lack
any real musical talent and are a bunch
of wannabe
rocker boys their racket revolves around
ticket scalping
faking autographs and providing the
occasional muscle protection
everything they do just seems to be a
pretense to try and get themselves
more fame and attention before we move
on i want to mention a couple
other random gangs that didn't really
fit anywhere like the piranhas which is
a
party gang whose only goal is to party
hard
hey excuse me excuse me i don't know why
you don't know this but y'all are
partying in a monster's stomach
thanks i love dancing or the bay area
rapid terror
which is actually a more traditional
gang that isn't that goofy
but i wanted to bring them up because
their name is a reference
to bart san francisco's stinky public
transportation system
but now let's move on to my personal
favorites the poser gangs
groups that model themselves after
famous people or pop culture
a very basic example of a poser gang
would be the western stars
a group that dresses up like wild west
gunslingers and only uses revolvers as
weapons it only gets weirder from there
though
over in nashville is the elvises a
pretty large group where members pose as
elvis during different periods of his
life and whose leader is referred to as
the king
they also claimed to have proof that
elvis lived until 2002.
along the same idea as the elvises we
also got the edisons who all model
themselves after famous inventors
and the kennedys a gang based on the
kennedy family nothing bad
ever happens to the kennedys
and then there's the willow sisterhood
it's made up of a bunch of young women
who are all sculpted to resemble
famous women in history they are also
deadly assassins for hire
speaking of murder there are the jack
the rippers
a gang of serial killers who mimic the
historical murderer of the same name
they even go so far as to wear 18th
century overcoats and
top hats how they haven't been caught is
beyond me
perhaps the most unique of the poser
gangs is the personalities
a gang with no specific theme rather
every member's role is chosen for them
at complete random with no say in what
they can be
roles can be practically any famous
figure from any point in history
after being assigned their new role the
member is biosculpted
to look like that person and they must
stay in character
for the rest of their life poser gangs
aren't just based on real people but
fictional ones as well one of the more
frequently mentioned poster gangs
is the brady bunch a gang that
bio-sculpted themselves to look like
members of the 1970s american sitcom
the brady bunch keeping on the sitcom
train we also have
the gilligans a gay gang where all of
its members base themselves around
characters from gilligan's island
there's also the coneheads based on the
old saturday night live sketch
i am beldar this is primat and connie i
trust we have arrived at the
pre-designated time coordinates
my absolute favorite though has to be
the trekkies
a gang who all model themselves after
star trek
today was another scorcher with a
temperature soaring to new heights the
increased violence between the steel
eagles and trekkies showed that human
temperatures are also running high again
today
the leader of the steel eagle said he
would nail admiral kirk's head to a post
before the end of the week
the police are ready according to police
spokesman james rajid
that's right in the world of cyberpunk
there are people who get
cybernetics to make themselves look like
main characters such as kirk or picard
as well as the many aliens of the show
like vulcans
klingon or borg their home base is
designed to look like a starship
presumably the enterprise and they model
their weapons to look like the classic
star trek phaser
cd project red if you're watching this
please work out a deal with cbs to get
the star trek license for a dlc
add-on it will be the best thing star
trek has done
in years but even if that doesn't happen
i do hope that cd projekt red
embraces the weirder side of cyberpunk's
lore
the original pen and paper game is
simultaneously a dark
harsh take on the future as well as a
tongue-in-cheek satire of american
culture
and i'd like to see some of those
ridiculous gangs make an appearance in
the game
imagine coming across a gang where
everyone is dressed like characters from
i don't know say a popular polish
fantasy franchise it just spin out some
ideas
people there had metal in their heads
waged war from a distance
using things similar to megascopes and
there were no horses
everyone had their own flying ship
instead siri stop fooling around
told you you wouldn't believe me but
that's going to about do it for this
episode in our cyberpunk lore series
the details from these videos was
sourced from our telsorian games
cyberpunk books so see the description
for information if you're interested in
checking those out
and of course check back every week here
on gamespot for a new cyberpunk video
thank you very much for watching
[Applause]
[Music]
you